this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
handsome chin handsome chin looking
muscular looking good with those tats
you know what I'm saying still drinking
still it's all right sliver on the
weekends I can't give your liver though
all the time off yeah your liver your
liver is losing the round of Life chips
they don't need a liver just cleans your
body yeah you get another one get
another one what's going on big gold
Berry you know what buddy how about
Obama how about big gold barium now more
more information coming out well I sent
you that we should pitch in what what's
funny is I post the big old Berry bit
from the show on social media and
becomes such a political thing where the
woke laugh gets all upset I'm like this
isn't on the left or right no it's fine
I'm just a gay man yeah that's all I
don't care like it's not a big deal but
you're present I think it was a great
president I mean he made a lot of
mistakes but I don't know the issue with
him as the president he's one of the
best most professional presents we've
had probably the best speaker yeah I'm
all for it this has nothing to do with
that this is past him running the
freaking free world yeah it comes out
like gay you have some fun with it well
it'd be called Berry time he was a
regular at a man at a at a gay bath
house now whether he was whether he was
doing anything I mean I'm sure he was
and sometimes you go and you win I sent
it through the group chat with you let
me send to Chin so they know what we're
talking about it's very interesting to
me that this is this is uh isn't it I I
said it's interesting how it's coming
out now I told on the group Channel you
know where it's coming out now this is
what's fun I said this outside nobody's
safe left right no nobody's protected no
no once they once they pulled that card
on Trump and it's like all right
transfer release the hounds yeah Obama
sucks dick like he's like what well I
hey I'm not even running like don't care
Hillary you're next let me ask you a
question when he was president I think
he was my age now you would be talking
to him and you'd be very respectful and
be Obama and in the in your wildest
imagination did would you ever think
that in his mind as he's talking to you
he's gone I would love to get me some of
this 100 and that could just give off
that Vibe but did you see I just sent
teaching you see his brother
someone him and his brother I guess
don't get along because he says now he's
fake and someone goes he you know does
he like men and he put the f word he
said yeah my brother's uh yeah what yeah
his brother yeah he doesn't know his
brother
well I don't know it's all confusing I
don't know
yeah I don't know I mean you know but
it's it's just a bummer it's nothing
political it's not the word rioter left
or conservative Left Right none of that
stuff you probably no this is just if
Trump if it came out Trump or DeSantis
or Mike Pence was doing this stuff we
everybody can get these jokes yeah
so is that Washington Obama a member of
Chicago gay man's club
in 2000 or May 20th 2017 2010 Washington
dc-based investigative journalist Wayne
Matson made a shocking disclosure
concerning Obama's membership in a man's
country homosexual Club in Chicago the
former president was allegedly nicknamed
Bath House Barry
a big old bear here's the thing be a big
old Barry yeah go try changing your
nickname is he is he is he I guess he's
an investigative journalist
yeah but I guess it was you like he oh
which is Chief of Staff Rahm Emanuel is
also a member whoa
a story about a guy who was uh no no
Jimmy Jimmy broke my buddy said tell us
a story he got in a hot tub with this
Greek guy and like he's in the hot tub
on a cruise and it was late at night and
the Greek guy took his pants off sure
and had a giant dong on him yeah I'm
with the Greek guy a giant dong and
Jimmy was like Jesus and then he gets in
the thing and Jim's like all right and
we're just talking but you know how
Jimmy can talk sometimes it seems like
he's okay
he's super animated super dramatic well
he's very animated he uses his mouth
you know what yeah you know what dude
and sometimes he does this with his
chest he starfish he's like really he
splays his little abandon for me for me
now now here's the thing the guy was
handsome strong jaw uh uh about 185 a
rock knocked out a great big ass and
legs clearly an athlete that's how he
talks about men are the same same guy I
stole all my stuff from him and uh and
he goes he was talking to the guy and
the guy's just kind of like yeah he's
talking and he just felt the guys how
foot oh yeah kind of sweep his leg just
accidentally on purpose just I mean
Virginia though you hot tub later night
on a cruise ship yeah that's like going
to haunted house being upset there's
ghosts that is hey Doug he met a
Brazilian gal there wait so did Jimmy
suck him up well
on that cruise yeah in the story he did
not however it gets better because did
he tell the guy like nah man come on bro
he didn't he just pretended like it was
nothing and then uh I think he got
sodomized uh but that's how that's a big
gay guys they're gonna shoot and they'll
know very clean shot take a shot he he
on that cruise there was a Brazilian
famous
uh yes famous race car driver I don't
know if it's from Brazil Spain's a
famous formula one guy and he had um
this well she's a she was a 12. yeah
from Brazil from Brazil a 12. sure and
and the guy was a star the race car
driver was a stud so you know you see
that couple and you go well that's you
know and uh and Jimmy
Jimmy started to talk to both of them
and then start he can dance and was
dancing with her and he didn't he got
seasick so he went to his room sure and
Jimmy was dancing with this Brazilian
girl she didn't speak a word of English
and then um he had sex with her oh yeah
you didn't see that coming no you didn't
see that coming in his room he sure did
in his room he was in the captain Suite
because his dad used to uh actually book
all the cruises so he he had sex with
her in the captain suite and then from
that the whole yeah from the whole
cruise on he was doing that every night
and uh and while the F1 driver was just
sick I'm sick I gotta go back upstairs
okay babe hope you're good yeah wow yeah
how about that and he said she was
can't believe that she's choosing me
uh you know a guy who plays pick up
basketball who's a sometimes working
actor
and let's be honest Jimmy doesn't even
have eyebrows yeah he's not hands he
doesn't have eyebrows he looks we're not
described Jimmy in a thousand words he
looks like a red bumpy pickle yeah uh a
good body and a piece on him sure
Charming is all [__] get out and the
prince and he can dance and he can dance
his teacher kiss the dance man and he's
funny as [__] totally unique he looks
like a cancer baby he's an original yeah
well you know he's he's if you're into
tall dark and handsome he's he's more
he's more medium red and and and very
very smooth very smoothly
um but she uh yeah she took him back and
yeah yeah he would have she didn't speak
a word of [__] English not a woman
driver has no clue yeah she said
something they were dancing and she said
you go you want to go drink uh he goes
yeah she goes but the bar's close she
goes we go to your room go room oh he
was like
I think I think this is very good yeah
you ever have that experience when
you're a younger man and you're all of a
sudden you're like this girl likes I
can't believe this is that's the
original Jimmy Burke that's not yeah I
know yeah I know what you mean that's
Jimmy Burke from uh there he is fellas
he's a handsome kid come on
yeah those eyes
there he is Irish is the day is long yep
Irish as the day is long turtleneck
there he was when he was younger
just kind of that was just really white
he's he's so white yeah well he's yeah
how's your flight flying all over uh Hey
that hurt first of all guys is everybody
okay is everybody okay I'll do be fairly
he did get dice in some spots like my my
street is a disaster as in what there's
some water oh I wish that no it
literally it took it took the road it
took the road and moved it it's a
disaster
it wasn't a level five hurricane
you got taken down to I think just a
level two trial it's raining it's
raining raining hard that's right
it's hard yeah where you're at didn't
you okay yeah it's gonna be tough to get
on my driveway I'm not gonna lie to you
no B I like all jokes aside I don't know
my street is like making me mad now you
know I'm on my street is just no it's
you know how you go down like this on
the road the road is gone so it's a
problem dude how's your how'd the road
go away I guess all the water flooded
underneath it and moved it probably
lying I swear on my life I'll take a
picture for everybody and you do that I
promise we'll go ahead and do that yeah
the road's gone bro get washed away sir
dude part of the road I'm getting angry
now you know I'm getting real mad now I
know it's annoying so hey but everybody
else is fine it's just where I'm at my
my ex my ex is going to drive the kids
over and you know I don't know if you
got that that flash flood warning I was
going hey I can I'm like you're in Santa
Monica
I had to go get some of the air on the
side to caution with these things yeah
well I went to the grocery store to buy
some steak for the big UFC fights which
you get to yeah bro it was like you
remember when we went through that yeah
I know let's get the toilet paper
dude people are loading up on toilet
paper water I was like come on bro and I
was like but if this does if this is a
hurricane yeah they're gonna be way more
prepared than me I like to roll the dice
though man well I need to start I'm
actually going to start I got to get a
serious prepper kit going for real yeah
you and I should go do a prepper and
shoot it no no no I'm gonna get some
pepper I gotta get some prepper stuff I
mean you don't think you didn't even
believe in this you didn't believe in
them
you don't believe in that but I didn't
believe in that you don't believe in
this tropical storm yeah you don't
believe me anyway yeah you think Oprah
started the fires in Hawaii you know
what you're annoying me dude well yeah
me and Sam got into that oh Sam blue oh
he tried to tell me it mean Sam did the
show yeah for the uh North Hollywood
comedy Festival we're there back I'm
about to get on today he goes dude you
see these fires I know it's terrible man
it goes dude you see like Oprah's house
and stuff it's fine the other ones Sam
stop stopping tell me when I get back I
don't want to fill my head with this
before I go on stage dude yeah just save
it dude yeah save it I don't think she's
behind it no but uh I'll listen he would
say I'll entertain it he would say that
she and all the all the it's the land
crab they say it's a land grab but
somehow they were able to control the
fire and I said and the CIA apparently
can control the weather so there's a lot
of talk going on that drives me nuts
but they are those grasses a lot of dry
grass that's not indigenous to that
Island I don't wanna I don't want to get
into it I don't know I was thinking that
when you were talking about how the
rains got to you how the people in
Hawaii might be a little annoyed here
what do you mean
you know tropical rains
and why did you see those videos though
of them in the water that was Armageddon
apocalypse why do people why would
Hawaii be mad at me well because they
just went through that Insanity that the
real the fire the real fire yeah that
wasn't a storm that was a fire yeah real
damage but what's that do with the
tropical storm here
he's saying you're complaining about
your street disappearing well Hawaii's
going through the fires no no you didn't
think it was real my street got ruined
[__]
you're also you don't think Hawaii would
be upset about it I think you're a fat
liar just like you said you saw [__]
mountain lions yeah I'll take a picture
I'm telling you apartment why but that's
not even a fun story that's stupid
that's just stupid yeah I don't like
your story I know but don't you think
Hawaii be more mad that you don't think
like you're complaining that and there
are weird people affected by this storm
you don't think that would upset more
people than me saying no I think my wife
was terrible I stand with Hawaii
did you donate you clearly were like why
me why me in my street no it's like what
happened it's funny because I called I
texted alien Marshall I want to do a
stand-up thing to benefit uh Lanaya so
we should do that yeah the standard
things take a while to get rolling they
need money now [__] yeah but we can do
it I get an idea the two grand I owe you
I say you donate that to Hawaii
that kid that's a good segue
which I won no I won oh yeah you did win
I'm stupid you're stupid
hey stupid but I won this one didn't I
yeah still owe me three grand
no no I'm up three grand no no we're
even what are you talking about no
because Izzy was five grand this is two
grand oh get get the [__] money that
you need from FEMA after your road
disaster hey here's my thing with that
do I call the city I hate to be shitty
right there
for reals who do I call who do I call
for that I'm sure they have bigger fires
to put out don't pun intended at least
who do I call please record it all right
yeah but they kind of watched a bit of
my when you see it you're gonna laugh
you kind of watch a bit of the road away
goes away you guys want to take care of
that they're like are you kidding me
dude it's hilarious good luck in L.A
because it's really efficient they'll be
right out we'll be there in four years
yeah
yeah I mean it's did you watch the
fights I did watch the fights I did dude
where were we at on Saturday
um I was I was uh start traveling right
yeah okay stop traveling I was here I
was here I know I know I know believe me
a little much little much
um so let's go through on Saturday let's
go through it uh I felt a little bad for
you Neil magni God is that was tough one
you called that I told you in Gary you
got to educate yourself on he's the next
big big thing so damn talented
Big Two for the division tall good at
everything and Striker oh man but
confident confidence all the confidence
unbelievable horrible fight for Neil
magni horrible fight for now I think two
judges had 30 26. that is 30 12. was
that a horrible fight for Neil magni
because he's just not on the level as a
striker he's not at any level for it's
just Ian Gary's that Ian Gary's top five
Talent wow he just says go through the
necessary steps just a matter of time
it's not if it's when yeah what is his
background kicking ass just kicking ass
in England or in Ireland or something oh
yes uh he's uh Irish don't say England
yeah yeah he's Irish sir and then he uh
I wanted to attendance on chapter I
wanted to fight shot next
shot
I don't know shotgun so damn it who is
he he's a badass right now oh is he the
Asian guy he looks Asian yeah that guy's
a badass
elbow in practice that's going to be a
very interesting fight well no I want
that to fight it's not I didn't announce
it no you and Gary called out Wonder Boy
and wonder boys like I'm good yeah so
he's six he's six he's a he's he's a top
seven you want to see Shopko because if
it's striking because of his no because
they're both two monsters Young Lions
have them fight now and then they'll
fight again down the road
um I think they're gonna do Wonder Boy
versus tomorrow Usman in December I bet
uh well well
what's going on with kamzo go back to
the fight what's going on with Comstock
well what do you mean he's playing Polo
custom he is okay
because there's a lot of fights for Ian
Gary like that like coms ought to be
good well he's at 85 right I thought I
thought uh pumped up at 85.
I've got 70. heat I thought he fought it
no oh okay
um how about her boy Chris Weidman did
you see what's that one tough to watch
yeah
39 it's 39 come back to that lead leg
injury and then apparently he tore some
liguins in his left knee now
as I'm still coming back like uh no
Daniel's like please retire he he did
you should go on Rogan's podcast yeah
and he went look he he he went through
it he you know he fought the whole fight
and it's like it was tough one yeah but
also UFC could you do me a favor and
toss him a bone not Brad Tavares coming
back the guy with remarkable take down
the fence it's still pretty active can
we get him he gets his comeback can we
be cool could you give him like a can I
know can we do that for the All-American
be nice right former champ Utah some
Brad Tavares yeah it didn't go well
I actually think this hurts Conor
McGregor's chances and the Conor came
out and said that the UFC and the usada
said he's not gonna fight December he
left a voice message saying they told me
it's not happening I'm trying I'm ready
to go I think the UFC watching Chris
Weidman come back from the same injury
went oh no no no no no no no no we
shouldn't have done this really yeah so
then because that injury was so bad he
never come back the same yeah and Connor
said I'm ready to go with the saying I
can't fight and you see like no no we're
gonna wait on this
so now he's not fighting in December so
hopefully he fights early next year
what'd you think you're wayle beating
the [__] out of that girl I didn't see
that that's the only thing
I mean bad news I mean just Total
Domination one judge gave it to the uh
home girl really lameos yeah
they should be fired what they gave a
round to lame one round yeah insane I
saw the Marlon uh Cheeto Cheeto Cheeto
is just standing banging away but that
that Pedro Munoz did a good job he's
tough yeah but um I had a thought about
that if Cheeto fights Sean again they're
gonna fight well that's what sugar wants
to do next and and
um
my thoughts because I'm a huge Cheeto
fan of course and uh she's a close
friend same I love Sean I love Cheeto
um I could argue in any faster I could
argue that Cheeto should be next that
um Corey cinnamon could be next and
marab could be next well I can argue for
any three you want so with Cheeto if you
watch the way he fought Pedro
you know and maybe it's because Pedro's
a different height and stuff that he was
he was kind of standing right there in
front of him and he was he was you know
exchanging I I think that's that
strategy would not be favorable if you
were to fight sugar Mally that's what
Cheeto does though applies pressure
boxes at that range and he just hits
hardened everybody yeah doing sugar he
just hits so goddamn hard so he'll trade
your two for his one that's what he does
like Pedro early on was Landing volume
but Cheeto was doing the damage yeah
that's why he won the fight yeah but
Donna Cruz same thing firing away find a
way lion came over yeah like cheeto's
just waiting for that knockout
but he's a slow slow starter would you
say now that Sean O'Malley's just
special he just seems to give he's one
of those guys he did it the reason I
kind of bet on him was because he seems
to have his best fights when all the
pressure he shows up he shows up that's
that Championship like like I said on
shop show I picked aljo and it wasn't
any knock on Suga it was I just thought
it was Al Jos it was his time still I I
didn't realize this I thought sugar was
a meat champ just not now
was dead dead wrong yeah and you know I
I uh I know there's a couple things one
of the things about sugar is that like
people think well these guys flamboyant
he's got you know all the dresses up and
he's got all this stuff going but that
dude is as disciplined and as keyed in
when it comes to his training his diet
and they all are at that level though
that see that that's not the yeah I hate
when people he's so dislike I know all
of them are though every single one is
that doesn't work for me it's only in
the UFC only it makes martial arts
people go that guy's disciplined in Anna
have you ever been watching NFL game ago
Patrick Holmes works really hard man
yeah you're right but I've heard they're
all Pros now I've heard from other
fighters who say like um like Habib used
to say a lot of guys don't train the way
I train they only train and camp that
way right so so some of these some guys
but but Sean's that way year round like
most of them are so it's cheap now you
have to be Cheeto is for sure is for
sure all Al Joe's the same they're all
the same
it's so weird to me it's only in UFC
where people that guy's disciplined dude
oh is the professional athlete
disciplined yeah and then maybe we don't
man Kobe works his ass off yeah yeah
they all do yeah they're at that they're
professional athletes and you'll see
they all all those top tier guys Izzy
works his ass up fukunasi works that's a
given yeah when you're placing a battery
you have to yeah you're not gonna make
it John's the only one where the kind of
but not now now he's dialed in but now
it's a different game now it's the money
it's more professional people coming
after you have too many young lions like
that guy Machado Gary come to him not
ready see what happens Savage he did an
open workout in a bar the night before
I know how confident that kid is but
O'Malley is um he's a special his timing
everything
is considered he also had a remember you
also got to give UFC credit sugar had a
year to prepare for aljo gave him one
year he knew he's gonna find him to give
him a full year to work on the timing
everything aljo took the fine remember
he didn't want to fight right away he
won more time and he was injured um yeah
he was like my shoulder's not 100 I
don't want because remember they have to
beat Henry he's like no let's do it next
year you know what you're remembering
that you're fighting boss and he's like
I don't want to do this remember not
taking anything away from him too
apparently yeah sugar was injured yeah
going into the fight couldn't wrestle
yeah
I'm just saying the UFC you know that we
know who you can we know who the UFC
wanted to win as as a champion you as
the champion can't say I'm not ready to
fight they can and they'll they'll just
go okay you can yeah aljo's just never
got along with UFC really he's just
like when the crowd was Boon I'm yelling
[__] out Jones was like man what is
going on with this guy so [__] up yeah
he's such a good dude like don't say
that about but he's also a champion you
know how hard it is to get to be you
know how hard it is to be Al Jermaine
Sterling you know how hard it is to get
to that level like what do you do if I'm
out I'd rather have that than them not
care like there's some Champions not a
long time but there's been Champions
before people just don't care you want
you want either be love or hated you
want to be in the middle yeah so for Al
Joe he's hated that's all good they're
still tuning in when you lose it's you
know does he get an automatic rematch
now I don't think so yeah you'll see
because certain if it was different even
though they like Sean at that they like
Sean they like Cheetos fun matchup yeah
Sean's good for business cheetah is a
great match and Cheeto is just colorful
those two are cheeto's a star too he's a
star I I think they're I think he's
gonna go Cheeto Corey sanhagen then
maram I think I put Moab on Ice oh
really yeah that makes sense I
understand but again if I'm the UFC if
you're gay what would you do business I
want I want the guys going to Grapple
them down
you know I mean Rob speaks English but
it's you know it's not fantastic but
he's also not the same caliber of guy as
as far as star quality of the sugar so
if you use your sugar is just colorful
it's not like Cheetos easy it's not like
uh koi sanding ZZ but those are funner
matchups yeah just what you got to do as
a business yeah so I did hear it on uh
Anakin Florin the podcast that Ray Longo
was in the locker room with uh with the
algae Mane and then Sean Shelby asked
algeman do you want a rematch and he
said yeah we want the rematch so there
is talks about a potential rematch
instead of I would uh I think you I
think I do usually side on the air of he
deserves it yeah how long was he
championed hardly the best of all time
if anybody deserves him
fight in December though who would you
rather so is Alger going to cut that way
in December
that's tough dude who would you uh
who is besides who is who would you say
Sean Sean's biggest
um yes what about sahuto
I don't know what aljo did to sahudo I
didn't know he was older how about how
the most exciting fight exciting fight
Sam Hagan San Diego's the funnest match
that's cheeto's fun too yeah and there's
a story there they beat him before they
they don't like each other yeah he's
sure got on the mic went cheetah won
tonight was he born let's do that in
December I love it they go well they had
they had house man winning the first
round and he goes really how'd they
score the stack
yeah I guess you give them the first
round the first round was weird and I
didn't realize how big sugar was either
I'm like oh my God he's way bigger than
Al Joe's big my size I'll just like wide
because all that weight looks small yeah
and like you said he just didn't realize
like the timing and the the movement of
sugar it's tough when he tells you I did
some quote-unquote flow grappling with
Tim Welch and sugar and uh this is sweet
they bring me in I'm just it's the three
of us and I'm doing flow grappling yeah
and also known as waste of time yeah
it's so fun though and Sean Sean so like
they're just nice in fact but Sean feels
like a piece of just Metal He's just
it's just a piece of metal and and my
size roughly my size yeah that's paper
of 35 I mean it probably walks at 165
yeah yeah
but he's got a tailpiece that's good for
the UFC tail piece also I've never seen
the UFC ever in the history of UFC
released the full knockout ever never
full Main Event they they released the
full Main Event the night of the fight
what do you mean or at least a day after
or something like that oh man I saw it
right away yo right away everywhere
social media YouTube entire fight on
YouTube I think two things here you
correct me if I'm off on this chin I
think one I don't think the fight sold
like they thought
and I also think too that uh suga's
audience is younger similar like Jake
Paul so they illegally stream the fight
so they wanted to get out to the masses
be like look here's our star here you go
here's the free fight like damn the
night of
so I think it's smart by you see because
they're going it's going to get out no
matter what we might as well be the ones
that get out and set all the illegal
streaming this is the younger audience I
guess otherwise why would they do it
um
yeah
yeah that makes a lot of sense anything
anyone yeah as far as the numbers though
I I did hear the their stats was like it
was like the biggest bantamweight thing
but that doesn't mean I don't know how
much weight that is you know the biggest
bantamweight the paper you're saying is
the biggest bandwidth that's what I'm
hearing co-headlining or yeah because
they're co-headline it
because waylay in the in the other girl
they're not bringing numbers
I'm surprised that way isn't bringing
big numbers in China she they said she
brought 1.9 billion social media
um like trying to get a tweet yeah
that's trying to tweet that's a lot yeah
yeah but but that doesn't equal
pay-per-view Buys in America it doesn't
that's right in China it's free I think
right or they don't show them at all
they just assume she's undefeated her
and the leech are just undefeated
well she's got the only one person
that's got waylay's number
Rose yeah that goes gives you an idea
how good roses you said you trained with
her what why do you make that face I
don't think Rose is the same now
her head's not into it yeah it's tough
it sounds you know sounds like she's
dealing with that stuff and Wei's gotten
a lot better her grappling's gotten a
lot better since then when I think
Tatiana swarza beats the [__] out of her
yeah because because of her what her
wrestling yeah
what what is what is going on with rose
she's a fight she's going up a weight
class though she's going up she has a
fight you said that she's she's like the
same thing he's super super athlete yeah
hmm
I'm gonna ask you a question man
do you watch the fight I watched
everyone except for the way they went
which I'll go what are we doing during
that
I know hey
and I don't care it's we're all friends
here dude I watched all the fights you
did I promise yeah I did we'll have on
the other ones
well I watched uh name it one other
fight don't bring it up I watched the
main event sure I watched the uh Machado
Gary fight
I watched um
I watched some of the the Weidman stuff
I didn't watch the whole thing I just he
was getting his legs keep going though I
know he was on the prelims I watched uh
two other prelimp fights the tough
Fighters yeah I'm staying on the main
card though the main card I saw the main
fight you saw yeah you saw the
highlights of this no I saw the whole
fight I watched the whole highlights
it's me here I watched the whole fight
what would you like to know about the
entire fight I can tell you the the
title fight yeah the one they released
the whole thing tell me about it now now
how did you score with a black share
fight the what the black show
the black chair yes what's that versus
Batista
on the main card that's the one fight I
made
you missed way light too the co-main
event I watched I did miss way so let me
get this straight you only saw yeah
the first fight and then yeah and the
last yeah but you came back because you
know you [__] up right because he came
back and said you watched the in Gary
fight
which was in the middle of the card yes
because I can explain that I was on a
plane back from Vegas
so you're streaming the pay-per-view
from your phone I had it streamed from
your phone it wasn't on my phone it was
on my it was on my phone it wasn't my
life wait and I don't know I don't care
I'm telling you I can exp I can break
down the entire first fight the O'Malley
fight yeah it's all over it's all no but
I saw the whole fight so the first round
was no no no I know you saw the main
event no yeah but the main event I knew
uh prove this that I watched the main
event I knew that aljame was in trouble
when I saw Sean stop that takedown and I
went hmm interesting now no I know he
was the main course I mean fight
um but I watched the Ian Gary uh Neil
magni I watched uh all the three prelim
fights and how did you feel with the
engaged Behavior
I didn't understand why he was giving
him the finger and stuff what was that
about because he he got mad that so
Maggie said something yeah
wasn't even supposed to fight him there
was an interview before the fight I
don't like when you're giving somebody
the finger after every round Neil magni
he said something to the effect of once
you become a father you learn how to
whoop ass and I'm gonna whoop his ass
like how I do my kids not exactly like
that so even Gary ran with it was like
he beat his kids and he was like I'm
gonna beat the shell this guy he's a kid
beater I think it was just a product of
Neil Maggie not being good at [__]
talking it was just making that bad
reference yeah and then these young kids
run with it and he was like no oh yeah
yeah that that that was I didn't like
that and also I just don't think Inger
needs to do that I don't either well
here's the problem Ian Gary was
outclassing the [__] out of him and
really [__] his legs up and then when
you see that and you see him like just I
mean I literally magni just didn't have
an answer and didn't even I don't even
think he threw a punch I don't think he
ended up and the problem with that is
that then then you're giving him the
finger you're talking about a guy who
has 31 fights in the UFC he's talking
about a guy who is a true first of all
he's a good guy I've never heard
anything about it such a nice guy he's
also like a Class Act he's also like uh
he's been there way longer than Ian he's
a vet so when you're giving somebody a
finger like I'm saying military vet yeah
bro yeah yeah he's in the Army yeah well
that's another one so you're giving him
a finger you don't need to do that it's
low class
but people say that's like he's always
been that way since he was a kid part of
it's like why he's you know he's a
killer and it comes with your
personality but I think as you get as
you mature he's a young man how old is
he 20. 25 25 is a killer but as they as
as I I would say as his coach or
somebody's older I'd say hey hey Ian
you're awesome you don't need to do that
and you're you're you're you're setting
an example now or his Idol is Connor I
know but but Connor's gotten worse
through the years right so that's I I
would say to him be as good you don't
need to you can be a prince you don't
need to do any of that you you can be a
killer that's just not like you want
people to be authentic you can be a [__]
talker you can be colorful like Sean
O'Malley but you don't have to give
somebody the finger especially a veteran
I agree especially when you're beating a
break yeah I don't I don't like that I I
I personally I think that's that's not a
good thing you just have yourself a
little magic mine yeah I do man yeah
that's what happens how you feeling I
feel great
it just hits you like like what I just
had I feel amazing
I'm thinking the last time we did this
later of a pod is when we did jelly roll
[Music]
jelly rolls later but yeah it's me Jeff
dye and jelly roll
oh do you know I started watching you
remember love love on this love on the
Spectrum yep respect him of Love
whatever it was and whereas the kids
yeah you know those kids are on the
Spectrum they're trying to find love
there's a new one called down for love
and I'm not watching you should no it
doesn't mock people downstairs I know
but I just I just don't know it's cute
No No it should make you sad
it should make you sad that dude on the
right that girl on the left doesn't have
Down syndrome what no she she has
something else oh but that dude on the
right speaks five languages
he's smart as [__] writes the most fire
poetry you've ever seen dude this dude
is fire he's a professional photographer
he's crushing it five languages
his poems Day date one he's like I I
love you he speaks in like a I forget
where he's from
I forget where he's from but he may not
be he may not have Downs hey hold on
full blown dance relax look at him full
blown dance be cool you've never seen
anything smart you haven't seen this
like you didn't see the papers speak
five languages or does he no he speaks
five languages straight up he speaks
five languages but he uh his poems are
so intense dude 30 minutes to know this
girl goes can I read you a poem she goes
yeah dude he was like I want to feel
your lips on mine he goes I love you
forever and ever I want to I want to
spend the rest of my life with you and
you're like God pump the brakes bro but
these kids with downs and the kids on
the Spectrum they're in dude they make
that connection like seahorses all right
dude they make that connection and it's
forever yeah you wish you had that love
dude you wish you had that love
I'd say right there Carlos bigaman yeah
this dude don't [__] around bro this
dude a real Casanova real Casanova then
there's another dude there's another
girl and she's an actor and she's
full-blown dance her story's sad her mom
passed away her grandma Midway through
the show has a heart attack it's a that
one's sad she goes to Grandma no you
should though she's super cool but they
pair up with this kid who he's he's like
the Frat bro he's a frat bro with downs
and he's just too much and they're like
dancing he's like shaking his dick and
the the instructor's like is that too
much friendships it's a little much and
she's like hey if you could just take it
down she can't though can't stop won't
stop and then they get her on her own
and they're like is there a connection
goes no we're friends like you can tell
him she's like no I think it's better if
somebody else breaks his heart not me
they're just Savages dude yeah they know
right away what do you hear the words
development level at that age I mean I I
some of them are stuck in it all I
looked it up because I was curious about
Down syndrome yeah and some of them are
like stuck at like eight-year-old 10
year old and then some are Advanced yeah
some are Advanced and then there's a
misconception that uh people down
syndrome die early no no no I think the
average life expectancy of downstairs
I'm 60. okay but for uh if you're this
one's crazy if an African-American went
down syndrome at average life expectancy
is 30. oh no not weird why I don't know
UH 60 is very young though isn't it it's
not that far off only 12 years from the
normal
70 I think the average look at the
average life expectancy nine isn't it I
don't know see what they are 68 bad
didn't you think it was way earlier it's
I thought they died at like less than
four years older than me sir all the
[__] right it's like my buddy the other
day was saying how old are you 16 now I
go
[__] no should look up the normal
life expectancy of just a regular person
I mean what do you mean yeah a regular
person bro
I thought it was like mid 70s be it
might be
of women of a normal person you could
just be a person
73 73 dude so it's only three years or
13 years more man I only have 13 more
years to go well a little more than that
20 years but well no I've got 13 years
don't look at me like you're [__] sad
don't look at me like that good stuff
man annoying but that's anywhere Down
syndrome six he's not not terrible in
the normals 13 more 73. but you think
people and then there's nothing about uh
Down syndrome women can't have babies
but not without but not what they CA
they can but not with Down Syndrome men
there's only been like three cases ever
because they're they're even their
sperms a little off yeah they don't swim
the right direction yeah so but if a
regular Down syndrome or if a regular
person without Downs has sex with
someone with Downs they can get that
woman pregnant
the more you know interesting and then
there's certain on the Spectrum where
depend where they're at mentally where
they can live on their own and be
self-efficient but for the most of them
yeah roommate for life you got a
roommate me my girl were talking like
can you imagine man those parents God
bless them the patience they have them
my mother tells a story one of her good
friends she's got two interesting
stories about this one of her good
friends one they went to a psychic in
Lebanon
in the mountains seems legit and this
woman wouldn't take money
because she was afraid if she took money
she would lose her ability so my mom was
like that's interesting
so she went they went to the psychic in
the mountains and the woman said
um she looked at my mother and she said
you're going to be fine she didn't even
let her she goes you're gonna have a
good life she said you have a you have a
a guardian angel that's about the size
of this building
I'm sorry does the psyche have Downs
how's this relationship she looked at
the other her friend and she said she
looked at her hand and she said um
you're gonna have a you're gonna have a
child that you have to take care of the
rest of your life meaning down and our
kid had downstairs in that while it is
really interesting like
stuff that was crazy then there was a
woman uh she had another friend who was
diagnosed with terminal cancer and she
had two small children and uh she looked
at the doctor my mother was with her and
uh she looked at the doctor and she said
uh the doctor said you know you have to
get your things in order because this is
very very this unfortunately there's
nothing we can do and you know what the
woman said she goes no
and then what happened the doctor said
what do you mean she goes I'm not going
anywhere I have my children I have to be
here for so I won't be going anywhere so
my mother was like well we can get a
second opinion she goes I'm not getting
a second opinion and she went to a
monastery she went to a nunnery up in
the mountains of Lebanon again and she
she died at 80. that's not bad no I mean
she died at 85 she she beat the cancer
she went and prayed she went and prayed
for 10 days and came out and you know
this is interesting things that's
interesting all across the board now now
I don't know I don't know
but those stories are true yeah
I don't like that Mom has some bad
friends come in with your fishing net
yeah I don't know I don't like you you
know you do you take your probe and you
start probing around yeah that thing
sounds fish you start going so should be
canceled by praying I don't like that
you you dip your a stick in my pond and
get all and started poking for I don't
like the temperature
looking for a fishy Pond here yeah man
I'm telling you there's no fish in my
pond no I know what you're saying I'm
not believing it get your stick out of
my pond why can't you just take the
story why don't your mom go to psychic
in Northern Hollywood because that's not
where they're at this was in Lebanon she
didn't take any money
she said your son you're gonna have a
son who's a sometimes working actor
the mom went all right all right he's so
good on the road not great he's gonna
sell just hey you know what your mom
goes does he have your computer she goes
now now I just told you now here's the
thing he's gonna sell well he's got San
Antonio this weekend we're doing pretty
well we got Salt Lake City the next
weekend doing pretty well psychics we
got we got some theaters we got some
theaters we need help yeah yeah
broadcast.com need some help on the
theaters might not be a theater act yet
yeah
psychic you know what
I'm still young and I still got time
oh dude it could I mean Louie didn't pop
for 20 years
yeah that's what else to say man
sometimes it doesn't work out buddy
that's all relative I think it's working
out for you it's all relative I mean
you're not it's all relative I practice
that every day all [__] aside I one
thing I never used to do now I wake up
and I just look at what's great gay what
I have yay nothing does anything worse I
wake up my toes hit the ground I think
God damn it okay another day here again
before you even finish it okay my buddy
Timmy used to do that like I'd be like
be having a conversation and like you
know me I'd like I'd get an opening and
I just open up and everything you know
it's funny because my dad traveled a lot
so I didn't see him much I always wanted
to impress him so I would he'd come in
and I'd I'd have a joke or I'd recite a
movie and stuff and Timmy just go yeah
your 60 minutes is up bro
I'm like [__]
I need three things three things you're
grateful for go yeah there's a gay okay
I don't know you can do that anymore
just clip your wings you sure can you
can I'm not gonna tell him you can do it
yeah you're fine nobody's listening I
keep telling myself I'm gonna do a
little that uh
nicotine yeah all right you're ready to
win it man with that heart
ticker the old bum ticker thumb ticker
get a bump chick
that was when I when when that girl had
we were we were in uh Seattle and that
girl had to have her phone on because
her she had a camera on her dumb dog
that was 27 years old I couldn't see it
couldn't even walk it was on a couch and
it had it had two heart operations and
I'm like yeah you got your dog with a
bum ticker could go at any time you were
dying that's a bum ticker
looks like he's dead nope he moved yeah
dude this dog was on like in Heaven's
waiting room dude just he was like I
don't know what we were doing the dog's
like why I'm at a comedy show oh God I
was like God get a kid dude what was
that theater called in uh Seattle I
don't remember it was a long time ago
you know me I got bored I was like what
are we doing I know she's giving this
song about the dog I thought we've done
that a couple times when we're sitting
there with people and I just gotta start
[__] I made it in Austin let me wear
hi but yeah oh my God I was about to
fall out so funny oh my God all right
Jim what do you got bud
all right this is not a big deal but Kid
Rock was recently at a I guess his
buddy's concert what this is a huge deal
what holding a Bud Light can Dude after
he shot it up like four months ago
was that before or after maybe we have
no maybe he had no options that's what
people are saying like that's the only
thing there but still you just wanted to
stay true you think you would be like
hey if they're like all we have is Bud
lighting I gotta have some bear man like
oh his Bud Light I don't know can you
bring in a plastic cup yeah bro if
you're gonna if you're gonna be that
outspoken those far-right people are
like traitor
that can cause some problems
for forever yeah ticket sales I don't
know I mean I think people are over it
now to be honest yeah I haven't heard
Bud Light yeah you know that's fine
people are like halfway I mean not
everybody Budweiser should pay the price
when one [__]
you know I like ice cold Bud Light
there you go well there are good good
people that work at Budweiser and
Anheuser-Busch that need a job yes so I
don't think all of them should be out of
a job because
dumb marketing lady didn't couldn't read
her if your kid rocks but the message
said they lost a lot of money
yeah so it's a silly one here but also
simple treason
Temple treason
treason
[__] dimples ruthless treason he's
joking though yeah yeah it's hilarious
did Kid Rock say anything though I
haven't seen you like I had no other
choice dude so have you seen this
there's a Spanish football president and
then uh so This Woman's team won the
World Cup she kicked the game winning
goal dude yeah and then he just he said
he was like overcome with emotion and he
I'll show you the video of him kissing
her I see I saw this is this a Spanish
thing yeah no no she just she said she
didn't like it oh I don't like that
either I mean
it's her coach that's a coach give me a
break
he just he was just like excited [__]
off
damn calls for his resignation [__] you
are you kidding but I mean if that was
your daughter you wouldn't like that
either right that was my daughter like
yeah that's weird yeah yeah
did he just her everybody on them just
her
it's just these dumbass people [__] you
sir coach [__] you I don't know if it's
a coach is it the president it's fine
it's fine hey she's fine everybody but I
made a mistake for sure I've accepted a
moment of emotional I need bad attention
I talk to people in Ukraine they're
having a hard time [__] off we saw it as
something natural normal
um let me did she say anything she said
she was on a live stream and then they
asked her what she thought it was I
didn't like it that was pretty much it
though
[__] you relax Brian no she won't it's
so dumb they won this they won the
[__] world cup and he's allowed to
just get carried away [__] off that's
her coach I mean probably frowned upon
Debbie kissing him but I don't think he
should be canceled I know it wasn't like
uh it was just a quick you know I'm
gonna kiss you like that it is weird
though right in America in America we'd
never Zoo nice remembers that it's fair
as a human in Disguise
opinion that's that's a so that's a sun
bear I believe yeah but look they they
stand yeah they're amazing I mean does
that look like a human
oh that thing looks suspected [__] even
like the yeah this part here
that's Brian's ass look at his feet
and now look at it
[Music]
Alex oh I don't know not regular blue
yeah it looks like working it looks like
that suit looks like it's got a suit on
though and it's all right that's what
people are saying wait let me see it
again
[Music]
but is his face moving or is it stuck
in the same position the beers just do
that with their mouths just leave it
open like a dumbass oh yeah my land
sunder
what's in China though I don't trust it
I don't like it I don't like it I think
it's it might be Joe Biden I don't like
it
yeah it looks like a bear to me
real bear they are dangerous sun bears
are [__] dangerous there's a China
Zoo like we gotta mix this up kill a lot
of people hire somebody a slave
basically steal them from at one point
the sagging skin around the Bear's hips
resembles and no fitting parachute yeah
it's a bag of draws
what do you guys think real or fake
I don't trust them
I mean it looks tits so this is Blac
Chyna I guess she's been getting in
shape I don't know
she got rid of the stuff on her face too
she's looking great fillers but see this
right here this has to be some stuff
right she took the pillars out of her
there's a lot going on but she looks
matches in shape I'll play the video
real quick
y'all see it yes ma'am come on
please
strong gals
she looks so much better once you got
rid of that stuff
she's definitely in shape though that
looks hard to be mobile when you have
those big fake titties and asses yeah
is there some one stroller uh anavar
going on there I think there's some
ozympic going on there and a Clean Diet
a zampac
yeah that works but she was never like
overweight right she just had the can I
see can I see her when you can you
scroll down and see what she looked like
before yeah see I like her like that
personally but
I don't know but she wasn't happy Brian
yeah
it's more fake than that beer what was
Blac Chyna she was uh she she had a kid
with Rob Kardashian
was she a musician at all or no yeah
she's a rapper but Rob doesn't look like
he's been missing any meals Rob that's
all that's that's trauma wave dude yeah
that's trauma weight what's his sisters
are the Kardashians there's a camera in
your face and you're saying that socks
I see so what's he up to Danny's really
close with his dad who passed away from
cancer tough life yeah and he's really
close with Lamar Odom who almost died
and then his sister breaks up with him
so that's all trauma there supposed to
be a good dude
does it you know how they still film the
reality show on Hulu doesn't want to be
part of it right if he's around does it
if they're around doesn't come over he
doesn't want to be part of it he uh God
bless him he's got that uh he looks like
he's a stress eater like you know the
depression yeah that's what that is yeah
been there you've been there
no I've never I've never seen him no I
have to be around there sometimes but
never I've never seen him yeah
I don't think he comes around you know
you know the other Kardashians a little
bit yeah I don't think he comes around
to the family functions
he doesn't like what they're about good
for him
that's how he feels doesn't want to be
on camera yeah that's all that's that's
stress pounds but
do you know have you have you met Kanye
yes
what about him dude have you talked to
him spent time with him
he knows who you are
I doubt it probably just a white boy
with a face man
I'm not Jewish so he talks to me
[Laughter]
true
what else you got Jen all right I saw
this post not that long ago this is in
Huntington Beach somewhere and it looks
like it's a
I mean it just looks like a gay couple
that got into a really hardcore fight
here
oh when gays fight they fight ask cops
it's the worst domestic violence they
stumble upon so you see them arguing
here they're sitting right next to each
other two faces real next and then he
had to he had butts in my hair oh that's
a good headbutt then he punches punches
them in damn
throws down there look and he's going
out there spike in the chest like a
vampire with the umbrella
yeah when gays fight it's passionate
fights dude and look oh body shot oh
body oh
oh oh damn
I mean the other guy's not even trying
to hurt him though you know this guy's
just like going after him but dude you
know what's great about this you know
what's great about this makeup
boy I bet that's bad though well I bet
you get they got into them bumps after
this now you need a guy your size to get
those two guys off those are too big big
yeah after two lovers and a Lover's
Quorum like in the middle of that
damn that's crazy [__] though that looks
twist his dick off that look the the
black guy just just looked like he did
not want to fight yes black guy does he
have him on an arm bar
I don't know what he has looks like
there's some Gage Jitsu going on in the
beach
that was a serious head Button Man and
serious punches too well I'd love a
follow-up well there was a body shot
that was a punch I mean yeah I wonder if
he caught the other one it looks like
yeah I was gonna say it looks like
somebody was banging somebody else you
bad boy yeah
who Todd is this his page no this is me
it's a page called meanwhile in
Huntington Beach so this happened in
Huntington Beach there's like two videos
but they're pretty much the same thing
so there's no resolution I I think it
might be too straight guys
I mean why would you
I don't really think yeah
let's watch this fight I assumed that
they're again oh no they're not gay I
thought that's what it said they're not
gay oh no plus they have little
heartbreaks uh emoji on it so it's
giving us the impression that they're
gay it's a headbutt and a punch two
punches that guy wait Jim you think
they're gay because they're sitting so
close to each other their girls could be
in the ocean oh look also I say the
story about now watch watch now watch
watch um
that guy can punch man I don't think you
get
I don't know dude if that's your
boyfriend you're not this is a fight
over this ain't nothing
yeah this is bad it sounds like that
looks like if I maybe [__] girl now he's
got him in a Half Car Store there and he
gets him an arm bar he goes from
mountains I didn't see that yeah yeah
someone that lends up in an arm bar I
think that's a guy breaking off yeah I
think the other guy already let him go
at that point so red hat right here
yeah
I see you're saying yeah yeah see now
he's already out
and then this guy's holding him oh yeah
are you trying to get arm bar but see I
just I read the headline a story about a
lover's quarrel on the beach part two
damn but are they lovers that's what I'm
thinking they're lovers that call I
can't imagine I don't know I don't see
how anyone would think those two are gay
but it shouldn't even say Lover's Coral
right let's just say two dudes fighting
those are those are two guys that are
very straight who happen to bang guys I
mean you know yes they are you know what
I mean I think it's over the girl you're
not head button a dude damn especially
especially if he didn't even take his
glasses off especially will fit your
your balls in him that guy that guy that
white guy is a looks like a tough [__]
he just looks like yeah but he's like
hitting to do this he's used to some
violence he's done that before I promise
you that
um are you aware of this police injury
yes no the cop goes down the slide oh my
god dude this is one of the best videos
I've ever seen so funny just watch bro
if you haven't seen this it's like a new
slide in Boston
I did not expect it at all
holy [__]
well [__] that
what the [__]
and also who goes down face first like
that
he got [__] up he was going down
the best part is it's like keeps it all
[__] one more time
he got knocked out or something huh
for sure yeah he got days because you
ever been down the slide you go so fast
it burns yourself
go ahead Tim he's all oh my God there's
not even that many turns
does he say anything he gets off I don't
think he can
laughs
I mean
no it was so awesome
oh my God that guy got raped oh gosh wow
oh let me pause this real quick oh this
is a a new childhood football star
you've heard of baby Gronk this is baby
Patty Mahomes check it out chin baby
jump oh baby
[Music]
why
okay
perfect shot yeah
the best QB ever
uh
um yeah let's go put chill burrow
the poor cop
go ahead Tim we're waiting for you um
this is my day that was my favorite
videos he feels so on athletic
oh man it's like it's like we got on
this raft and the boat was taking us
where you do this and [__] the guy
was going too fast and all of us just
went [__] kind of like that you're just
you know you're like oh I gotta go back
in this wasn't fun there we go some of
those water
terrible story hey in the middle of the
story I was like you wanted to bed she
said someone died but the the water
slides now are so intense you see like
they're like 50 stories up straight down
thing but because the the water there's
something about where the the the
pressure you stick to it because gravity
but man if and that's why they say don't
don't jump off step off so you stick to
the water if you jump you're just
following all those stories oh my God
it's too much what is that is that a let
me see that's pretty [__] Waterside I
remember the Story water slide
decapitated boy yeah oh what yep in
Kansas like it was like no it's like oh
is that Kansas City yeah oh because this
the name sounds crazy like verrucked oh
my God it's a German name yeah oh my God
I see I don't get down with those I I
don't I don't it's not for me Max Speed
70 miles an hour in your undies come on
man that's not worth it they always look
dangerous I don't get down those water
slides it's too took that poor boy's
head yeah but I heard it'd take his head
off how I think maybe you know how
they're like cylindrical like that oh so
maybe yeah lift it up and then you're
distracted that dude the rest of the
kids were like what I can't even think
about that horrible I can't even think
about it what else you got a chance yeah
well I didn't want to end on that but
that's oh wow I don't think I have
another one oh guys I hope you're crying
into your meal uh
now this is kind of lame too but
what the zero freaking bail policy so
you know like all these malls are
getting like
flash mobbed yeah right so that happened
right over here in Canoga Park that's a
pain
Rogan said to me goes time to leave La
yeah because you know because he used to
live over he knows if the mom knows that
he's flat but the the L.A County they
have a a team now a task force that are
like they have like way more officers
way more uh patrol cars for the mall but
we'll see
yeah 50 Cent we kept saying even before
once that zero Bill policy came in that
you know so that means you don't have to
post Bill if you do something like
vandalism or theft something you know
small misdemeanor yeah so these guys are
just going to take over and do this
constantly yeah you're trying to make
his political change you'll get a kick
at it you'll get a kick out of me my
naivete I uh my son uh my son said if I
get a black belt in Jiu Jitsu will you
get me a Rolex I go I'll get you a Rolex
if you get a black belt in Jiu Jitsu
right 10 years yeah I said in 10 years
you stick with it that's worth
investment that's a good investment on
your part 100 yeah and uh do you say
which Rolex but he's in that he's like
you he's like he likes nice watch oh
he's asking for Daytona he just likes
nice watches he saw that like the one
with the blue face he saw oh wow he
knows watches yeah oh wow yeah it could
be he also he knows watches he knows
cars he knows clothes he's like it's
really interesting like he reads about
it sounds like my son yeah not yours and
um and it was so funny because uh I I
walk in and I go you know I'll just go
to Rolex and get a watch oh no the guy
goes no no no no that's not how it works
my buddy
he just bought a watch it took him a
year and a half he was on a waiting list
yeah you're in a waiting list or you can
get them secondhand Market but they're
marked way up yeah like you just can't
it's just it's like Ferrari's
Lamborghini yeah you can't just walk in
and buy them you have to be allocated
that and then you gotta you're on a
waiting list but there's so you can get
around it with some shops we'll put you
on the list but you're still looking at
probably your weight wow there's ways
around it though but it's dicey what is
the sure we could find if someone if he
wants like a Daytona no he's gonna catch
some pennies Daddy no I'm talking about
it I'll get him a nice watch but like
that stainless steel watch is great
still 15 grand what's stainless steel
the Rolex
Submariner you get them uh yeah yeah
there's all sorts of stuff what is the
cheapest uh Rolex you can Submariner
probably just the the silver Submariner
so you're probably looking at uh you
know probably 10 grand okay see that's
the most common one see the black some
sub there that's nice this one yeah and
that's used 10 grand wow
give me used one yeah
that's what my dad told me if I made it
my dad told me if I made an honor roll
to get me a snowboard and I was thinking
like I'm like looking at snowboards you
took me to Play It Again Sports
give me that 100 used snowboard joke's
on me I didn't read the fine print
didn't read the fine that thing was
marked up but boy was I proud of it yeah
I love that thing yeah well I told you
my son made the baseball team operation
Summer complete they weren't giving
those parts they weren't giving that
away no they have the first practice
Saturday kid's an athlete
I can see some of that video yeah we'll
see
him you're delighted it's not football
right no he wants to play football we
saw him for football too but if I prefer
he grav dates towards uh about her
business oh I don't know that was a
twister you know the black chair of the
guy that fought that you didn't want oh
this looks great this was great
look at him
just look at the smile on his little
face dude he wants to go all the time to
the gym all the time look at it whenever
we have free moments go all the time and
he I have to pull him out of there I
think it's done he sees it like his
favorite players like Bryce Harper's
favorite baseball player sees him in
Asana
at the gym so now he wants to be in the
sauna but he had 10 minutes dude
at the gym not that gym just in general
he loves Bryce Harper
and he looks like a little stud yeah I
like days in the gym that I'm doing it
with him so I'm like all right I'll burn
some calories with you great in this
dope
dude we got Covina uh September 8th one
night two shows coming up and then the
next morning we leave for Austin we're
doing uh the companion with Joe Rogan
and
special guest Sam Tripoli Sam tripley
Eddie Bravo's gonna be in Japan so we
shout out the conspiracy bat signal to
Sam tripley it's gonna be good so you
got Rogan Tripoli calendar me baby for
Izzy vs Strickland that'd be fun man
yeah it's gonna be a fun one but the
night before we're in Covina Covina
Laugh Factory
Karina Laugh Factory two shows bring up
September 8th yeah I'll see you this
weekend everybody
um I'm at uh LOL Comedy Club August 24
25 26. Wise Guys Friday and Saturday uh
September one and two King Center
Melbourne Florida September 23rd and
then I got Genesee Theater in Waukegan
Illinois Sunday September 24th it's a
south of me so pretty it's like uh in
the suburbs it's right near Chicago
right outside Chicago or it's a little
north of me I mean yeah yeah so on a
Sunday
I guess Sunday oh theater on Sunday
hell yeah dude got to push yourselves
right I like it not bad right I like it
I'll get on an early flight come back
and do the podcast it's very good uh
bring your mind chin I got Covina with
Callan and then Spokane Washington my
favorite Club smoking watching Spokane
Comedy Club September 21st 23rd skank
Fest coming up Niagara Falls November
4th through the 5th and then we have
Iowa uh being announced in Chicago in
December all right kids thick boy.com
if that's looking good buddy dude well
done
well done on the set shout out to Brian
Johnson very good bye kids love you see
you soon